gentlemen I really want to start with a
sincere congratulations on this movie
you did not crash the Ferrari thank God
like like for real like I I am very
impressed with what you pulled off with
this film um and so I'm just curious did
you actually put a little more pressure
on yourself on this one because it's
Exorcist it's 50 years later and also
because Universal like bought a Trilogy
and spent a bunch of money to work with
you guys on these films yeah I
definitely felt pressure in a different
way than I feel I it's it's it's an un
it's an un familiar way to make
especially theatrical movies for us so
it was a new experience for me um um and
it it it is a double there's double
pressure there's pressure of the IP of
The Exorcist and pressure of the unique
deal around the three movies so I
definitely say I would felt felt a
little bit of added pressure I I'm I'm
always my own worst critic and my own
you know putting pressure on myself in
in ways that may or may not be the
healthiest but to me it's trying to
bring an Integrity to a franchise that
means a lot to me as a as a movie geek
and so just get the right team together
work your ass off and and make a movie
are you directing the trilogy or just
directing this one we'll see we'll see
we'll see we'll see the the idea is we
you know we built a road map that I
think has so many different um avenues
that we could we could take in the world
of exorcism and possession is so the
world of spirituality is is so curious
to me that there's so many um questions
that I have and as the movie uh finds
itself existing in the world over the
next few weeks I think a lot of those
those uh those questions will be
answered I think your reviews are going
to be very good and I think you know uh
I really want you to continue but uh
just throwing that out there um but I'm
curious when you when you Universal
signed on you guys worked with them to
to make a Trilogy so I'm curious with
this one knowing with the first film
that this is the first of three how much
did you figure out the the where you
ultimately want to go and how much is it
just it's movie by movie um I I like to
know where I'm I I like to know where I
think I'm going to go and then when
there's an opportunity or an
improvisation or a detour that feels
appealing or sparkly light over there I
I want to make sure I'm not so
meticulously locked into a structure um
or a concept that I can't deviate and
because so many of the things that I
love about making movies is those
opportunities that that arise in a
frustration or it's raining and you were
looking for the sunshine and and then
what you find um is is so amazing and
those Adventures can be so creative for
me so I think it's having a good play
and a good team and then being able to
roll with the punches and and uh and
have some fun I really enjoyed some of
your abrupt edits um some of your Cuts
very well done but I also want to
commend you on where and when you use
like demon shots and I'm just curious if
you guys can talk about where and when
you like you know not overdoing it but
making sure it's there uh can you talk
about those two things yeah well F first
of all to to credit my editor Tim
Alverson who very was very studied in
the original film and uh and the
Beautiful sound design work that on
fredkin film they had those hard edits
those those outs without seeing the
reaction or the response sometimes in
the middle of a sound an Abrupt and and
jarring edits that I thought were really
effective and and keep you uncomfortable
through that experience and so he
brought that um that concept to this
film and then in terms of the demons
that are you know there's also this is
not a big jump scare movie in terms of
those those um the Contemporary tropes
of jump scares because we're looking at
the original film again and there's a
couple of startling moments with Ellen
in the uh in the Attic in the original
film or those almost subliminal pizu
shots that they drop into it at the most
horrifying times and so we're studying
that expanding on it a little bit making
sure that this film is designed for a
contemporary audience and finding what
that line is of when you can can linger
in the world of character development
and the Slow Burn of it and when you
need to uh you know punch them in the
gut and twist for both of you uh I love
talking about the editing process
because it where it all comes together
so what did you guys learn when you
started to screen the film for friends
and family that ultimately or test
screenings that impacted the finished
film I I I love the screening process so
it does start yeah you start with
friends and family I have screenings
every week for a new unsuspecting
audience and I try to find sometimes you
go to the the the the deepest darkest
Exorcist fan sometimes you go to a
religious Guru sometimes you go to just
a group of moms and dads that don't know
anything about it and and you want to
see what different audience how
different audiences respond to it and I
know within my community and the my
friendships it's fun to get people
outside of the industry that aren't so
cynical about about what movies are
maybe they're not even a a Horror fici
in a they don't even like horror movies
and you want to see what appeals to them
or doesn't appeal to them about this and
one of the things that I was really
conscious of in this movie is as opposed
to a Halloween movie where there is a
lot of humor infused into those movie
even the scary moments sometimes the
aftermath of a scary moment is is there
to to to breathe and laugh about here
was trying to find where you do need
tension Breakers where you do need um
you know I don't know that this movie
has anything funny in it but there's
moments of things that are so
off-putting or weird or awkward that
then you do want to just your body can't
do anything but have that laugh and so
you study an audience's reaction to the
movie and and you don't necessarily
alter the movie for that purpose but
sometimes you do but it's nice to be
aware of how you're um how you're
communicating with an audience in a
horror
film I I would agree with that um um
this movie
specifically um you know we changed pce
stuff we changed a bunch of stuff no
different than the other movie when you
just just just just just exactly what
David said you screen and you I think
you I I always learn the most from
watching the audience take in the movie
as opposed to the other comments after
although we look at those two obviously
but when you you can really feel when
you're sitting in a room with an
audience watching a movie when they're
with it and in it and when you're losing
them and that's very important
information for the edit also say some
things that that you you would think an
audience would need to know for the
story you're telling but then you
realize like there would be some medical
procedure sequences and then you realize
we've seen a lot of movies we can cut to
the chase a little bit and so if we're
looking to condense time you can take
out some of the obvious things that if
you were going to tell the story you
might want them in but then you realize
the audience that are entering this
movie regardless of their vernacular of
movies they don't need to be told all
the details and ambiguity sometimes is
uh a lot more satisfying for that
experience than spelling everything out
for everyone I think this going to be my
last question cuz I'm going to be out of
time but how did you decide on the demon
the specific demon you wanted in this
movie versus I mean let me see I'll I'll
say that so so for the the specific
demon which I I still haven't said out
loud uh we studied Pazuzu from the
original film and the relationships
within demonology to um other uh friends
and family uh of Pazuzu and and how that
might apply to our story and that was
actually one of the one of the very
first things that we that got us rolling
is thinking of what we're responding to
and what is this demon after what is it
seeking um and then we got Christopher
Nelson is an incredible makeup team to
do these creations that are very subtly
dropped in there but again uh effective
when uh when you get those glimpses kind
of nerving yeah no 100% I got to stop
I'm just going to say guys
congratulations I know this going to be
a hit oh thank you thank you very
much